se trata de bar el mayor puerto de los
balcanes y la puerta de entrada a europa
central
el puerto se encuentran montenegro pero
china podría anexarse lo pronto de forma
totalmente legal porque por un escándalo
de préstamos que para montenegro se ha
convertido en la autopista al infierno
todo empezó cuando montenegro decidió
construir una autopista para abrir el
país un banco chino concedió un préstamo
de mil millones de dólares en 2015
seis años más tarde solo se han
completado 40 kilómetros en rojo en este
mapa
el proyecto se ha visto afectado por
retrasos en la construcción y problemas
financieros ya se han gastado los mil
millones
para completar el proyecto el gobierno
de montenegro tendrá que conseguir más
dinero
el primer ministro está furioso al final
de su inspección ni siquiera trató de
ocultar su preocupación
tengo que admitir que está la autopista
más cara de europa en serbia un tramo de
la misma longitud y topografía similar
costó 19 millones de dólares por
kilómetro y aquí costó 26 no entiendo
por qué existe esta diferencia con
serbia yo no pinto ni creas a montse p
corrupción y gasto excesivo
el primer ministro culpa al contratista
chino
la empresa trajo sus propios
trabajadores que son unos 700
viven en su propio pueblo lejos de la
población local los funcionarios chinos
se negaron a responder las preguntas
sobre el excesivo costo del proyecto o
sobre las consecuencias de una posible
quiebra
no
no no
si montenegro no de nuevo el préstamo
los términos del contrato le otorgan a
china el derecho de acceder a las
tierras montenegrinas como garantía
en el artículo 8 montenegro renuncia a
la soberanía sobre parte de su
territorio a excepción de sus sedes
militares y diplomáticas
de esta manera el país balcánico podría
perder el puerto debajo de línea ha
manifestado su interés por estas
instalaciones y se trata de un contrato
extraordinario que ya han aplicado los
chinos en sir lanka
el ministro de inversiones de capital de
montenegro no apoyó el contrato cuando
se firmó
reconoce que su país ha aceptado
cláusulas que no tienen precedentes en
europa
personalmente no habría firmado este
tipo de contrato sobre todo con estas
contrapartes a créditos creo que son
peligrosas para nuestro territorio pero
ahora que soy ministro tengo que
asegurarme de que las obras
de que esta autopista se construya y
tengo que eliminar el riesgo financiero
para pagar esta autopista que por el
momento solo conecta pueblos el gobierno
podría pedir ayuda a la unión europea
en la capital podgorica la idea ha
calado y la gente se dirige directamente
a europa
vamos a necesitar la ayuda de europa
para escapar de esto la unión europea no
lo va a permitir estoy 100 seguro
para ser sincero creo que montenegro ya
es un país vendido a los chinos a los
rusos a los alemanes
porque no a los franceses franck nuestro
territorio ya no saber colores con ese
anillo
aceptaría en los chinos esta solución no
se puede dar por hecho el contrato
especifica que solo los tribunales
chinos serán competentes en caso de
litigio